the girag an experience they found in
instances and I believe they found it in
like cave people and certain animals
they found cancer and all sorts of
animals yeah yeah and wild animals
they've found cancer in them it's cancer
is a weird thing and we can't assume
like what when someone is born with
certain diseases right we don't we don't
try to make some sort of environmental
connection always to the fact that
they're born with certain diseases even
people that are living in paradise with
no toxins in the environment there's
still the weird randomness the giving
birth to people conceiving a child and
the child coming out and what everything
has to be in order all the Ducks have to
be in the row to make sure there's no
diseases like with there's so many
variables man and one of the variables
is cancer and the fact that some people
get it and some people don't and some
people live their lives terribly they
abuse the [ __ ] out of their bodies they
take all kinds of drugs and nothing
happens
it's crazy yeah and this is people like
you they just live normal and they get
cancer and if you didn't pay attention
to it you could have died that's just
how it is the world is weirdly random
mm-hmm in that in that sense well it's
not fair genetics are not fair
intelligence is not fair
creativity is not fair there's no fair
there's no fair and if you start looking
for fair fares in your household okay
fares amongst your clan fares amongst
your loved ones fares not the outside
the outside world is a wild competitive
battleground of ideas and actions it's
not fair it's not fair at all and how do
you prevent that randomness from scaring
the [ __ ] out of you you can't man yeah
you can't you you just got to keep on
keepin on yeah there's no way you can't
if you prevent it from scaring the [ __ ]
out of you then you're not paying
attention to it right you'd have to
block it out completely if it wasn't
terrifying because if you were paying
attention to it's gonna be terrifying if
you're not blocking out completely you
look at the randomness
just the fact that we're in this planet
with no roof and we're hurling through
the galaxy and there's all these
asteroids out there and you know
sometimes they don't see them because
they're coming from behind the Sun they
just [ __ ] slam into us and kill
everybody yeah I spend a lot of time
trying to decide what freaks me at more
the infinity of the universe or the
infinite infinity of being dead
you know mmm like if any of the universe
any of that goes forever and once you're
dead well that's forever - right there's
this no no what's stranger this would be
the scariest yeah the infinity of the
universe if you live forever and you can
breathe in space and you didn't need
food and you were just floating forever
and go see what the [ __ ] going on you
can't doesn't you're never gonna land
you're never gonna touch ground I'm just
gonna float through forever for billions
and billions of years without ever
talking to anybody but you're never
gonna die that sounds terrifying that
might be the worst yeah that may be way
worse than dying yeah I think that would
be I mean what is worse than dying
wishing you were dead
flying forever for billions years you
know bored you'd be after the first
billion years and realized you have an
infinite amount of billion years left
where you're still gonna be alive
breathe in air with no need for food no
friends mm-hmm you know what you know
now we've been transformed by the gods
and to this this symbol of psychic
torture you're the god green that Tom
green in 2021 God came back to show us
all a lesson he let Tom green breathe in
space mm-hmm and fly on forever and live
forever right and then you you streamed
your thoughts can't land on a plane
going around there's no landing I'm
gonna be up in space forever be
frustrating to fly right by a great
planet and yeah one planet looks like
Lake Havasu would go to the top you go
and they're all drinking you can't go
down can you see it though how closely
come looking close enough to jack off
but then bear in the space again you may
not be so bad then you get every billion
years you come around Oh every billion
planet how this is not a daily fallacy
- three times daily
five times daily
[Applause]